space the final frontier but even out
there you'll still find daddy issues hey
folks so this one is a patreon sponsored
review and this when I got this request
I was immediately like alright I'm not
entirely sure what you're getting at
here but we'll give it a shot so I was
commissioned to review two episodes of
Star Trek Deep Space 9 so a little bit
of context I haven't watched Star Trek
Deep Space 9 like really at all I've cop
bits and pieces I know who some of the
characters are I don't I think I've seen
maybe one or two episodes front to back
I don't know which ones like I could
never get into it part of the thing for
me with that was that it had it had an
actual continuing progressing story as
opposed to being more episodic that's
not actually a complaint against it but
the only time I ever saw shows like that
was when I was spending summers at my
grandparents and I was catching them
sporadically so anything that needed to
be watched in order I gave up on right
away because I'm like I can't follow
what's going on just because of how I
was able to view the dang things so I
never got into deep space 9 but I was
commissioned to review episode 22 of
season 3 the explorers and then you is
either episode 2 or 3 depending on
whether you count the two-parter that
opened season 4 is one thing but the
episode the visitor so yeah going into
this I had no idea why I was being
commissioned to review these and I also
didn't know why they weren't even like
episodes that we're back-to-back so it
wasn't like two parts of a single story
what was going on here well having
watched them now okay I get why the
person who commissioned me wanted me to
review these particular ones so try
I mean I don't have to explain the
concepts of Star Trek Deep Space 9 do I
oh heck let's do it let's cover our
bases so Star Trek Deep Space 9 is set
on a space station as opposed to a ship
that is traveling through space so it's
it's something that theoretically stays
put and then you know it's got a
standard crew and other people come and
go and the station is headed by Benjamin
Sisko and Sisko has a son who I could I
didn't know I'd never encountered him
and like the little bits and scraps that
I'd seen over the years
I named Jake so the episodes that I
watched very much centered on the
relationship between Jake and Sisko that
was really kind of the core of it and if
I were to guess this is speculation on
my part I don't know for certain if I
were to guess I think the person who
commissioned me to do this have me do
the explorers basically as a way to to
get a sense of these two in their
relationship so that the visitor could
have more meaning because out of the two
the visitors the highlight by far but it
kind of did need the context of knowing
what that relationship was in order to
work as well as it does so props to
selecting these I'll put what the
Explorers briefly this is not gonna be a
detail plopsa not plop-plop oh boy but
synopsis of either one of these episodes
because I'm largely gonna be talking
about thematics since I don't know these
characters well enough to know if these
are good representations if they are you
know slightly off the beaten track
representations if Jake is even a
character that we saw much of in the
show aviary was a sprat like I don't
know so I'm gonna focus mostly on
theming and and that end of things
so the explorers it's got a number of
things going on but the a plot of these
floors is cisco decides to build a ship
based off ancient plans
of the Bajoran which is a alien race if
you don't know Star Trek this is just
gonna be weird names and stuff tossed
about willy-nilly bear with me and it's
basically an interstellar sailboat
it's a solar sailer and he builds it
using old-style tools old-style material
you know he could have fabricated all
this stuff but he's like no we're gonna
do it the right way he makes a project
out of it in the hope that his son Jake
will go on a little jaunt with him and
initially Jake is it's not a good time
ultimately he does go and the two of
them bond and Jake talks to his father
about wanting to be a writer and showing
him a story that he's written and what
was kind of nice about this episode is
like this a few other things going on
there's like a thing with the doctor and
his old rival from med school or
whatever but it was really interesting
because you you kind of expect in
somebody this oh they'll go out and the
thing is something you'll go wrong
they'll be stranded in marooned and like
they have a little trouble but that's
not really what it's doing it's a much
quieter piece in terms of focusing in on
that relationship and really zeroing in
on the way these two men well adult than
a young man interact and sort of the
crossroads that they're at with each
other as far as their relationship goes
and it was nice to not have that be
forced to share space with a more
rollicking action thing and it is just
allowed to be the bulk of the episode I
do what I need to say this and I feel
bad saying it because I always feel bad
knocking young actors the actor who
plays Jake you know and he's like 16 17
18 the characters I don't know how old
the ecto is but he's not great
he's not terrible and I suspect part of
the problem is the writing not that the
writing is bad but writing for
characters in Star Trek especially on
the TV shows like next generation and
Deep Space Nine and Voyager they tended
to speak very formalized they were very
well-spoken and correct grammar and
complete sentences and there wasn't a
lot of slang or you know the casual talk
done on the crew of any of these things
and that plays okay with adults
especially considering that you know
they're all Starfleet they have they
have training you know they they're
gonna be they're gonna be a little stuck
up but when you've got you know a kid
talking like that I'm like mmm
you guys did not know how to write for
somebody younger did you like at all and
so as a result a lot of his dialogue is
really on the nose and I don't want to
blame the actor too much I think it's
some of the lines he has they're not
they're not painful it's not like why
would anybody write that it's just like
boy that you couldn't find a slightly
more roundabout or poetic or subtextual
way to say that you just had to be mmm
so that doesn't help but when you're
sucking lines like that there's only so
much you can do I don't want to harp on
that though so as I said the explorers
is mainly set up I mean not directly
like I said one episode doesn't lead
into the other but for the viewing
experience I just had that was the setup
to the visitor now the visitor the whole
thing flashes way forward into the
future and we meet Jake as an old man
actually as Tony Todd Candyman himself
in old age makeup and apparently Jake
you know was was really well known as a
writer but he also stopped writing at
some point and nobody really knew why he
stopped writing and there's this young
woman who has you know found him
basically just wanted to say how much
his works inspired her
and that sort of thing and so he then
tells her why he stopped writing and
then we get flashback which gives us the
backstory and there was an accident that
happened during a wormhole event
wormholes going on at the station are
like part of the deal with what goes on
there but this was like a particular
kind that doesn't happen very often and
there was there was an accident and it
takes them a little while to figure out
exactly what happened but basically
Cisco got zapped out of time and
initially everyone just assumed he was
dead and but like a year later Jake saw
him like a couple years later saw him
again
[Music]
and you know I actually like talked to
him briefly and they kind of figure out
that you know you're not just seeing
things but the the whole nature of the
thing is cisco isn't aging
he just keeps phasing in and out but the
gaps between money's here and when he's
not keep getting longer and longer and
longer and longer and Jake gets frankly
a bit obsessive he he goes through a
period of trying to live his own life
you know he he gets married he writes he
get stuff published he he seems to have
had a good adult life man cisco shows up
again and for jake everything just kind
of spirals because he gets obsessed he
abandons writing and goes back to school
to study all these sort of experimental
temporal sciences to try and help his
father and that's where his life goes
that's why he stopped writing it's why
his wife leaves him it's why never had
kids
and when eventually you know he gets a
like a little bit more time with it with
his father but again he can't hold on
his father says don't don't keep you
throw away your life trying to reconnect
with
me what are you doing and so for the
last stretch of his life Jake does start
writing again
he doesn't publish it but he does write
and he shows these some of these
writings to Melanie who's the girl who's
he's sharing this story with and then
his father connects with him one last
time and it's as Jake is dying and for
wibbly-wobbly timey-wimey reasons if
they're together when Jake dies it'll
snap the connection and send Cisco right
back to where the whole thing started
and then he just has to avoid the
discharge that's that took a lot of time
in the first place and this whole thing
will basically be undone and so at the
end of it
Cisco has these glimpses of what Jake's
life was in his absence but also
obsessing over him sort of seeing the
impact on his son of his own lingering
presence like a shadow that almost kind
of consumed who Jake maybe was supposed
to be and the overall vibe of the
visitor in general it reminded me more
than a little bit of the next generation
episode of inner light as far as tone
goes as far as like showing a complete
life and having it be about you know the
things that get learned over the course
of a life and and I mean Tony Todd is
great I mean Tony Todd is a great actor
with a great voice so like even though
the old age makeup I recognized him
instantly so that that I loved and it
was really interesting to to watch and
to see and to sort of see the baggage
that Jake just couldn't set aside
couldn't let go it was interesting for
me to watch in many ways though
the this kind of story is hard for me to
relate to and it's not because it was
poorly done I think it was actually
excellently done but the thing for me
and I guess peek behind the curtains to
get a little bit personal here I don't
really have a relationship with my
father not really not in any serious
meaningful way
but I've also never like ate to have
that either have a very neutral
relationship with my father he's not an
active part of my life he never has been
I'm not angry at him I'm not bitter at
him I don't feel like I was abandoned by
him I didn't feel like my life would be
more complete if he was part of it
he just wasn't a part of my life and
that's something it's one of those
things people talk about you know daddy
issues and it's one of those things that
it exists on a very intellectual level
for me because I just I don't have
enough a relationship positive or
negative with my own father to really
have a lot of issues around it you know
I can talk to the guy it's but that's
kind of all it is and I suspect that
somebody with a stronger connection with
a father figure probably will get a
little bit more out of this than I did
which again is not say got nothing out
of it I think it was really well done I
just can't help but suspect that under
other circumstances this probably should
have hit me harder than it does and it
didn't hit my normal parenting buttons
because I am an easy target for that I
think because it's largely from the
perspective of the kid from Jake even
though ultimately Cisco's the only one
who's gonna remember any of this
we are getting the story from Jake's
perspective so if it had been from
Cisco's perspective and it almost could
have been like a bit like interstellar
where Matthew McConaughey watches the
the footage and watches his kids grow up
an agent he's not there to help with all
the struggles that they go through and
like and that seemed breaks me but
that's because it's from the perspective
of a parent which is a perspective I
have a lot more connection to but this
isn't really from Cisco's perspective so
that that might be why I didn't quite
connect with it as hard as honestly I
would say the episode deserves because
it is very good I'm definitely glad that
I watched it it's a nice showpiece for
what Star Trek episodes can do
emotionally and again I think that's
part of the reason why I tended to think
of the episode inner light which is
another one that's primarily an
emotional journey
Star Trek at its best really can do
wonderfully emotional and evocative
storytelling that isn't just about
aliens and warp drives and phasers it
can really connect to something about
the human experience and I think these
two episodes the second one the visitor
especially does do that it just happens
to be that in my particular case it is
connecting to a human experience the
head I have less experience with so
there you go Deep Space 9 explorers and
the visitor oh boy but this was an odd
assignment but I was happy I'm I was
happy to get it and it's nice hey
everybody so a little bit of an addendum
to this review between when I shot this
and when it goes up
my father actually passed away and I
suppose on the one hand it's odd for me
to mention it because I even if it this
had happened before my feeling I don't
think it would have drastically altered
the opinion I came away with him not
being here anymore doesn't suddenly
change the nature of the relationship
very minimal relationship that we had so
on the one hand I guess it kind of
doesn't really change anything at least
as far as this review goes but on the
other hand it felt very strange to not
in some way acknowledge his passing
given that it is brought and died my
kind of lack of a relationship with him
is brought up in this review so just
putting this here not trying to get an
outpouring of condolences or whatnot
though I'm sure it'll happen I'm not
gonna discourage it but I'm not trying
to get that it just just didn't feel
right to put this up without
acknowledging it I cannot honestly say
that I wish my father had been a bigger
part of my life and my feelings at this
point are complicated but it is a fact
that I am still going to miss him so
wherever you are now and wherever you
end up from here I wish you the best
Peter
you
you